foreign
has erupted between the government and
trade unions over exactly who's to blame
for the winter strikes the rail network
is frozen today with workers beginning
the first of six planned walkouts over
the Christmas period and nurses will
dare you to go on strike on Thursday now
they've accused the health Secretary of
belligerence and said he had refused to
offer a single extra Penny to end the
dispute we will be hearing what the
government says about that in just a few
minutes time and we'll be live at two of
one of what are usually the country's
busiest train stations but first a
political correspondent Maria rora
reports
for real passengers icy conditions cause
chaos on the commute
today things are about to get a whole
lot more difficult rail workers rejected
a new pay deal as relations between
unions and the government remain Frozen
in deadlock public sector pay is lagging
behind the private sector and nurses too
are feeling ignored by the government I
have made it very clear that if they
want to avert the strike on Thursday and
on the 20th of December and moving
forward we needed to get into a room
with myself to discuss pay or with
conciliation through aircast I went into
that room today with hopes obviously and
came out with not one single Brown penny
oh for God
and if ice and snow didn't cause enough
disruption public sector strikes will
add to chaos on the roads Rail and
airports this week
but government ministers insist unions
are to blame I would say what we've
tried to do is to take the politics out
of this by making sure that we have an
independent pay review body we've
listened to that independent pay review
body and we've honored the settlement
that they suggest
a Christmas season riddled with strikes
will do nothing to boost the
government's approval ratings in the
polls I fly back to Spain on Friday but
I could only do two days in the office
because of the strikes we just don't
know how to get to the airport so yes we
are exasperated and we are just hoping
that something will happen by then and
we will be able to travel we want to get
home we don't know how when the trains
aren't working
but unions too could yet face a backlash
from the public as families fail to
reunite for the holidays who gets the
share of the blame for the strikes
remains to be seen But the Prime
Minister risks being remembered for the
wrong reasons if his government fails to
come to an agreement with workers Mari
Aurora Sky News
well Becky Cottrell is outside London
Bridge station is at Birmingham New
Street uh morning to both of you Becky
let's just start with you and I suspect
not very much happening where you are
today
no it's been pretty quiet this morning
the station's actually opening late
because services are so limited many
trains are not running and when I
arrived there were a few people waiting
for the doors to be open but certainly
not as many people as you would usually
expect on a weekday morning in London at
a busy station like this I think many
people now are used to kind of how these
days run they know what they're in for
because we've had quite a few of these
strikes by now and in fact the message
from many train companies is simply do
not travel on these days unless it is
absolutely necessary and if you are in
Scotland or Wednesday you will find it
virtually impossible to travel because
most of those trains are down and this
of course comes on top of this icy
weather we're seeing which is already
causing problems for train companies and
passengers and really passengers can
expect this disruption to continue until
January the 8th there are several more
days of strikes but it's not just the
strike days where passengers will face
trouble often the disruption carries
over into the next day now yesterday
members of r t the union Behind These
strikes they rejected a pay offer from
Network around about two-thirds of
members who voted that offer had been a
five percent pay rise for this year back
dated to January a four percent pay rise
on top of that in 2023 and no compulsory
job losses till 2025 but the r t advised
its members to reject that offer on the
basis of changes to working practices
now another Union unite that represents
electrical control room operators they
have just accepted a similar pay deal
from Network rail but the rmt as I say
rejected it so for the next month we can
expect more strikes and more disruption
passengers oh let's bring in grumpy at
this point as well and go up some some
data out today which is giving us some
much needed context in terms of uh where
wages are at
yeah and there is a lot of information
in the labor market report but it's the
data on wages that Union buses and
ministers will be keeping a particularly
close eye on because the figures Today
Show that real wages that's wages when
you take inflation into account have
fallen again in October by 4.2 percent
it's among the biggest declines that
we've seen this decade and that quite
simply is at the heart of the industrial
disputes that we're seeing up and down
the country workers want higher pay
Rises to match inflation the
government's taking a look at the public
finances and said we can't afford to
give it to you or rather we're not
willing to put up taxes or to increase
borrowing in order to give it to you and
anyone who commutes to work will know
that this has led to An Almighty row I'm
outside Birmingham New Street Station
it's Britain's fifth biggest railway
station and at this time in the morning
it would usually be buzzing with
activity but it's eerily quiet workers
are having to make alternative to get to
work or the ones who can are working
from home and this this disruption is
likely to continue the government warns
that by putting up wages for public
sector workers it could spark a wage
price spiral whereby workers Chase
higher wages to meet inflation causing
the inflationary problem to become even
worse
but if you have a look at the state of
the economy some of those fears might be
a little bit overblown where already in
recession and unemployment is now
climbing figures from the ons Today Show
that the unemployment rate ticked up to
3.7 and it's likely to climb a lot
higher the bank of England has it
somewhere in the region of 6.5 this year
so that's not exactly the kind of
economic climate that we'll be
delivering red hot pay Rises to workers
grumpy Becky thanks very much indeed
uh while taking all together thousands
of NHS workers including nurses will now
strike uh this Thursday the 15th also on
the 20th in England Wales and Northern
Ireland ambulance workers and paramedics
Emergency Care assistants and coal
handlers are there due to be taking
industrial action on the 21st and the
28th uh what about the postal workers
They Were Striking yesterday they're
also expected to continue on a number of
days later this month now as we've been
reporting rail strikes will take place
over four days this week and from
Christmas Eve until early on the 27th
after their talks with the government
broke down border force staff driving
test examiners security staff on
Eurostar and some civil servants are
also walking out this month uh well
let's bring in our political
correspondent Ali Fortescue who's here
in the studio Ally simple question for
you the unions make the point that from
their perspective it looks like the
government wants these strikes to go
ahead is there any validity to that
I think we've seen a shifting tone on
the unions from the government I think
what's obvious is that they've moved
from trying to avert these strikes to
trying to
mitigate the impact this is going to
have on all of us we've got will Quince
yesterday talking about ambulances being
driven by taxis uh you know you've got
the Army stepping in to plug the gaps
that public sector workers can't you've
got two Cobra meetings this week the
government want to look like they're
taking it seriously like they're
negotiating talking to the unions
evidenced by the fact that we had Mark
Harper a couple of weeks ago talking to
the rmt that was significant that hasn't
stopped the strikes today though and
last night we had Pat Cullen talking to
Steve Barkley the house secretary but
both sides couldn't even agree on what
the basic reason for them being there we
had Pat Cullen talking about Dell
secretary being belligerent for not
being willing to talk about pay I mean
they said they said before the meeting
started they weren't going to talk about
pay that it was the independent Peabody
that it's given them the the the the the
rise that's what they were going to
stick with yeah exactly and you know
yeah you have both sides basically at
odds about the basic reason for them
being there is this the government
wanting to look like they're negotiating
or actually negotiate waiting so in the
short term there's no sign of these
strikes being averted but in the longer
term no sign of inflation coming down
certainly in the in the New Year and no
sign of this row over public sector pay
ending anytime soon
great thanks very much Ali sorry
uh just a quick reminder you can scan
that funny looking thing there on your
screen the QR code which will take you
to the Sky News Daily podcast at today
not me hosting it instead Sally Lockwood
she's been taking a look at her
industrial action and unions have
changed and what their impact might be
in the future she's been speaking to
Skye's business correspondent Griffith
Nolan who you just saw as well as
economics professor Len Shackleton and
Andy Pendergrast from the GMB you can
subscribe to the Daily whenever you get
your podcast
quick run through the papers and we'll
start with the Metro it leads with those
tragic events in solihull the headline
there victims of ice Lake
similar sentiment in the Daily Express
tragedy beyond words after it was
confirmed that three of the four boys
have died
I mean while the Daily Mail calls out
frozen Britain referring both to the
better weather and the strikes
foreign
reports on the breakdown of talks
between the nurses Union and the
government
and the guardian draws attention to a
report blaming a decade of Tory neglect
for the state of the Health Service
a ten-year-old boy who lost his life
trying to save other children who'd
fallen through the ice on a lake has
been hailed as a hero named locally as
Jack Johnson he is one of three children
who died in the tragedy a six-year-old
is still fighting for his life in
hospital Tom Parmenter reports now from
solihull in the West Midlands
it really isn't that thick but there was
enough ice on babes Mill Lake to draw
children out onto it
four were rescued but they spent the day
here checking to see if there were
others
of the four boys that were pulled out
three died later in hospital
one of the boys is a close friend of
Tommy those all played and awesome then
one got one other legs got stuck in the
eyes and two of his friends went to go
save him but they're all Fallen
Katie was at the lake just before it
happened on Sunday afternoon
they were just down where the entrance
of the water is on the solid here just
playing that's all I saw Christmas is
about children that's why we do it and
to know that there's going to be
children up there
it's just because of bab's meal like
it's weird it's a weird feeling
another boy age six is still in the
critical condition in hospital one of my
officers was trying to punch through the
ice to to actually rescue the the
children themselves can you just give us
some information regarding the ongoing
work here at the lake and whether or not
there are further people unaccounted for
we have to be 100 certain that there is
no one else possibly in the water at
this time
we it's important to stress though that
we've had no contact from anybody
suggesting that there's anybody else
missing
we don't yet know whether the boys here
were being supervised or not but once
the ice had started to crack it all
happened very quickly there is perhaps
no Starker example of just how dangerous
a frozen lake or Pond can be
families here applauded as one of the
fire Crews paid their own tribute
all of the Emergency Services here want
the story from this Lake to be a very
clear warning to others
searching on the water has now stopped
so they gathered in their hundreds to
reflect and to remember
they prayed too for the youngest victim
who still lies critical in a hospital
bed
Tom Parmenter Sky News Sully Hill
um seven people who are missing and
feared to have died in an explosion of
the block of flats in Jersey have been
named by police
the police say the victims were all in
their 60s and 70s and included two
couples another two are still thought to
be missing
children who spend a lot of time looking
at screens have a higher chance of
developing obsessive compulsive disorder
researchers in San Francisco found that
a child's likelihood of developing OCD
increased by 13 for every hour they
played video games and by 11 for every
hour they watched videos
there is a warning that Christmas lights
bought online could be unsafe
potentially causing fires or electric
shocks an investigation by the consumer
Group which found that 10 out of 12 sets
bought for 15 pounds or less failed to
meet safety regulations and shouldn't be
legally sold in the UK
now with the UK experiencing its coldest
day in a decade there are concerns about
the energy Supply needed to keep the
country warm in part that is down to an
unusually low level of wind power which
has been reinforcing stretched gas
supplies and as demand for heat and
power go up new figures suggest we're
going to get less power from wind
turbines in the future our science
correspondent Thomas Murr has been
taking a look
we are in the middle of a wind drought
for several days now a stiff breeze has
skirted the UK looping around from
Norway across the Atlantic but Western
Europe is there in the middle of it all
and it's almost totally calm it'll stay
like that for a while yet and that
matters because our wind farms are
almost all in Scotland and the North Sea
it's not until Wednesday or even
Thursday that the winds pick up and the
turbines start turning the lack of wind
is having a big impact on how we're
generating our electricity this has been
our Energy Mix over the last year wind
produced around 28 percent gas 42
percent and coal just 1.6 but look at
the mix from lunchtime on Monday gas
power stations have been ramped up
producing 61 of our electricity wind is
down to a little over three percent
about the same as being generated by
coal this snapshot is unusual but it
does show the limitations of renewable
energy in some weather conditions and
winds aren't likely to get weaker with
global warming these are the projections
on future wind speeds even if Nations
collectively reach Net Zero soon after
2050 they dropped significantly across
the Northern Hemisphere shown by these
shades of blue a phenomenon called
Global stilling and it's caused by
rapidly Rising temperatures up in the
Arctic in the UK winds are expected to
weaken by up to three percent by 2050
and 10 percent by the end of the century
right now the UK is taking a big bet on
wind we have 14 gigawatts of onshore
wind turbines and around the same
offshore but the government has a Target
to increase that capacity to 50
gigawatts and to turn off gas and coal
power stations by 2035. however having
the turbines doesn't make them turn as
we're finding out now and although the
government also plans to expand nuclear
energy to 24 gigawatts by 2050 that
wouldn't fill the gap left by the lack
of wind at the moment we will need to
find some other way of storing vast
amounts of energy or importing much more
through long distance cables if we're
going to keep the lights on
Thomas Moore there plenty more coming up
on the program at half past seven I'll
be speaking uh to Richard Janet to
discuss whether or not troops should be
brought in to replace ambulance drivers
and firefighters during strike
also this out I will be speaking to the
rmt at he'll be on their picket line at
London's Houston Station
I've been joined as far past it by the
shadow Public Health Minister Andrew
Gwynn
[Music]
I'm very pleased to see the transport
secretary Mark Harper joins us once
again in the studio Mr Harper lovely to
see you this morning
um
please don't take this a question the
wrong way but but with with trains not
running across most of the country as
transport secretary do you accept that
you have failed in your job no I don't I
have two roles here one is to keep the
railway industry working but also I've
got to be fair to the taxpayer there
isn't a bottomless pit of money to go
into the rail industry and I think if
most people listening to your show look
at the offer that's on the table they'll
think it's very fair and reasonable it's
in line with what most people in the
private sector are getting we've seen
unite workers at Network rail have
accepted the offer the tssa are
recommending that offer be accepted by
their members and even with the rmt's
very strong recommendation to their
members to not accept the offer to turn
it down to reject it out of hand we
still saw nearly 40 percent of rmt
members wanting to accept it so I think
the tide is turning on opinion about
whether these offers are reasonable or
not and therefore I hope the union will
look at it again call off the strikes
and accept what is a reasonable payoff
but just in terms of of the rmt from
their perspective it isn't just about P
it is about T's and C's did you or did
you not instruct the real delivery group
to insert Clauses into the the offer
document regarding driver only operation
trains without guards a reform of the
rail industry has been on the table from
the very beginning and absolutely can
you just answer that question did did
you direct the railed Recovery Group to
Putin driver only operation into the
document to the offer document no no the
detailed negotiations between the
employers and the trade unions between
them the overall amount of money
available obviously is something that I
have to set so the detail is up to them
the driver only trains are not a new
thing they've been running since the
1980s and over half of them was opposed
by every single Union representing real
workers since if that is not a wrecking
amendment I don't know what it is well
over half of passengers that go on the
railways they're on trains where driver
only operation is in in place and it's
been accepted by um train drivers so
it's actually not I want a deal here but
that's why when I met the unions I made
sure there was an improved offer from
Network rail an improved offer and an
offer came from the train operating
companies that hadn't previously been on
the table so that's what Mick Lynch
asked me when I met him and that's what
I delivered it's a reasonable offer for
reform and pay and I think the union
should accept it you genuinely believed
that the rmt would accept an offer
containing driver only operations
something that they have consistently
approved I mean miklin said this we went
on Sunday to to have the conversation
fully expecting the blanks to be filled
in on P the real delivery group said we
can't do what we said department for
transport have made us put driver only
operation into this document and it
strikes me that it looks very much like
you're happy for these strikes to go
ahead you inserted something that you
knew the rmt could not and would not
accept no look quite the reverse I don't
want these strikes to take place at all
they're bad for passengers
bad for businesses like for example the
hospitality industry which is going to
suffer or is suffering as a result and
they're not good for the rail industry
going forward I want the strikes to be
resolved that's why I made sure there
was an improved offer on the table and I
think some of the trade unions have
accepted it you know you say about
people not accepting it that one of the
trade unions is recommending exceptions
United workers except did it yesterday
and I think the rmt should think again
it's a reasonable offer on the table
reform needs to take place reform has
been on the table is he lying is he
lying when you said that he went in on
Sunday and the real delivery group when
instructed by the DFT to put in driver
on the operation as you're lying or not
I haven't been involved in the detailed
negotiations between the uh train
operating companies and the trade Unions
that's for them to deal with I I haven't
been doing that I made sure there was an
offer on the table which I think should
be accepted and reform of how the
railways operate you know seven day
working all of the other things that's
been on the table from the very
beginning suppose I suppose at least the
rmt should be appreciative of the fact
that you yourself are willing to discuss
pay with them in a way in which and you
know the nurses unions are not being
talked to about pay why does Steve
Barkley why does the health secretary
believe that he doesn't have to address
the reason that nurses are going out on
strike in negotiations with nurses well
first of all I don't think there's a
difference here I've been very clear
it's not my job to negotiate in the same
way the health sector is not negotiating
but meeting with trade unions and
listening to them I think is very
reasonable why is he Lots on repeat that
is the reason that nurses are going out
on strike they have a meeting he doesn't
discuss pay the nurses go out on the
street he's listening to their concerns
but on pay specifically you know we've
got for the Health Service an
independent pay review body that's made
a series of recommendations for people
who work in the health service including
nurses who we value absolutely we've
accepted all of their recommendations in
full the 19 pay rise that the nurses are
asking for isn't affordable I don't
think it's reasonable and it take money
away from Frontline Healthcare you don't
have to stick to what the independent
peer review body suggests you could add
to it so when we have the general
secretary suggesting they're not a
single Brown Penny mall was offered you
could well have done so had you desired
to do so isn't that the case well look I
think we've got to also look into
account what is Affordable and we've got
to you know what they're asking for
would cost 10 billion pounds that money
would come away from Frontline
Healthcare so it's about giving a fair
pay rise and for example we we value
nurses so last year when there was a pay
freeze in the wider public sector we
made sure that nurses got a pay rise
they were the only people to do so
because we valued them we've made a
reasonable payoff for this year which
the pay review bodies have recommended
that gives a 1400 pound pay rise to
nurses which means for the lowest paid
nurses they're actually getting a rise
of 90 is it fear that nurses starting
salaries have risen less quickly than an
MP salary
and since 2010 MP salaries have risen by
28 you know and you will accept that
nurses pay has been reduced in real
terms by between 10 and 20 is that fair
well look we we have accepted what the
in we have an independent pay review
body for people who works
you don't have to do what the period
would say well no but the pay review
bodies made recommendations about rides
in the past which we have accepted in
full which means the nurse will get a
1400 pound pay rise which is targeted
also at the lowest paid which gives them
a larger payroll than other people but
you've got to balance that against
whether it's widely affordable the most
important thing is that we get inflation
under control that's what's at the root
of a lot of these issues and that's why
we've got to balance rewarding
hard-working public servants but also
not having inflation busting pay Rises
it will embed inflation is it fair that
MPS wages have risen faster than
starting salaries for police teachers
and nurses since
as you know MP's pay is set by an
independent body we have nothing to do
with setting it at all you'll remember
that change was made back in 2010. So
MPS have nothing to do with setting
their pay was an independent body it's
not fit and they may not recognize that
independent Peabody got it wrong all I'm
gently suggesting is that when it comes
to nurses pay perhaps they've got this
wrong well look they take evidence both
from the government but also from the
trade unions they look at Recruitment
and Retention they look at all of those
things and they make recommendations and
we've accepted them and I think most
people will think that what's been
offered is reasonable it's in line with
what people are getting in the private
sector I think most people listening to
visible think they've had a reasonable
payoff for and I hope they accept it we
will see what happens on that front just
one last question though Telegraph and
times have been reporting that there has
been a deal done with Albania which
could speed up the process of getting
people who should not be in this country
back to where they came from what can
you tell us about that well look I'm not
going to comment on specular relation in
the newspapers but look the Prime
Minister thinks that getting migration
under control is incredibly important
he's been working closely with the Home
Secretary on this and when there are
specific things to announce we'll
obviously announce them in due course
I'll take that Minister good to have you
on the show thanks for joining us
no yellow weather warnings those remain
in place for much of the UK with the
cold snap continuing to cause travel
disruption up and down the country let's
speak now at this guy's meteorologist
Joanne Robinson uh Joe just how long are
these conditions likely to last
well for much of this week we're going
to keep the cold conditions but we will
see a change over the weekend some other
hair trying to move in over the weekend
so there is change on the way but for
now it's the cold conditions we've seen
minus 17.3 degrees Celsius last night at
Bremer so that's the coldest night of
the year so far and coldest since
February 2021 so here are the
temperatures at the moment we've got
minus eight in Edinburgh minus two in
Birmingham so freezing conditions and
some freezing fog in places too the fog
is most widespread there's some fog
across Northern Ireland where there's a
warning out and across parts of East
Anglia and into parts of the Northeast
as well so some freezing fog around icy
conditions particularly where you've got
that snow there's some flying snow here
where I am in Oxfordshire it's lying
snow of course down in the Southeast and
other parts of the UK particularly
Scotland so icy conditions that ice will
remain a risk over the next few days and
we will see some snow showers
particularly
um across Northern and Eastern parts of
Scotland today and over the next few
days and Northeast England and there is
a risk of something wintry across the
southwest of England through today and
particularly tonight so we could see a
covering of snow there so that's
something to watch and keep an eye on
warnings that may be updated throughout
the day so yes certainly staying around
for now
Joe many thanks indeed
stay right where you are the former
Chief of general staff General Lord
Richard Dunn tells us what he thinks
excuse me about soldiers being drafted
in during the strikes that's after this
foreign
welcome back quick reminder as to our
top stories and the transport secretary
has told the program that there is a
reasonable offer on the table for
striking rail workers
[Music]
a ten-year-old boy who lost his life
trying to save others who fell through
the isobelic in solival is being held as
a hero
and we had all NS figures out today
showing real pay levels Falling by 4.2
percent in October failing to keep Pace
with inflation
[Music]
no thousands of soldiers are preparing
to cover up for ambulance Crews border
staff and other striking workers and
that has prompted some complaints from
the military that they're being forced
to give up their Christmas former head
of the army Lord dannett joins me in the
studio lovely to see you this morning
um this is a difficult one because at
times of national crisis your first
thoughts go to the military and and the
service that they provide what do you
make of them being used to essentially
plug holes in an industrial dispute
well that's the key Point actually an
industrial dispute I think um members of
the Armed Forces and the Armed Forces
generally recognize that we are the
nation's reserve of trained Manpower
that can be used for whatever the
government of the day requires but
there's an interesting point
um we do that out of our spare capacity
in other words when we're not doing
other things now that was fine
um when the Army Navy Air Force were
much larger they're much smaller at the
present time I mean 75 000 in the Army
that's a long way down from what it from
what it used to be so spare capacity
isn't isn't really there at the same
extent now a National Emergency like
covid sold as a perfectly happy to step
up for that and of course they will do
whatever is needed to be done in these
circumstances but it is it starts to get
quite tricky when it's an industrial
dispute it's not for the military to say
whether the government is right whether
the unions are right we will do whatever
we're we're required to do but the other
factor is that you know here we go again
around Christmas time a lot of soldier
Sailors now and have been involved over
the last few years and here we are at
Christmas time again I remember years
ago when I was commander-in-chief we
were regularly turning out for fire
disputes as commodity if I got in touch
with John Prescott and said this is
going to stop we've actually got our job
to do in Iraq and Afghanistan get the
farmer to do their job we'll do our job
and it's the same I think today
um Mr Lynch tell his Roman to get on and
run the trains
um we'll do our job so um I think
everyone does their own job it works out
much better and bear in mind military
had pay rise of 3.75 a lot of these
people are on strike for double digit
pay Rises that won't go down 551 on the
nappy
what though of the very specific jobs
that they're being asked to do um
obviously soldiers will have combat
medicine training they will have first
aid training very very high level of
course but it strikes me that perhaps it
is not the same skill set that a
paramedic driving an ambulance has one
of them being used for that specific
rule well my understanding is that the
rule that they're fulfilling is to drive
the ambulances with paramedic trained
individuals
um on the ambulance as well and I think
that's that's fair enough I think that's
appropriate yes of course
um all military particularly deploying
on operations are trained for for
Battlefield medicine but that's not the
same as delivering help when someone
dials 999 Drive the ambulance is fine
let the paramedic is sitting in the
other seat do the paramedicine I mean I
suppose the other point to me as regards
is that the the broader issue of of
soldiers you know helping out during
times of of industrial unrest now
soldiers can't join a trade Union
Soldiers can't go on strike can they
they can't and I think this is something
that the government needs to think very
carefully about soldiers will do what
the governments today wants them to do
of course they will but one has to think
how appropriate that is it's one thing
to step up when there's a National
Emergency there's a national disaster or
something but it's quite another thing
to have to step into an industrial
dispute I I think the government needs
to be very careful about that yeah I do
wonder what kind of effect this will
have on morale within the four seas that
at Christmas time and as you've
mentioned already there have been more
than a couple of years us where you know
the military has been working at
absolutely full tilt I mean do you do
you see people leaving the profession
over there well I can see people
thinking to themselves I got 3.75 pay
rise and these people are looking for 10
to 15 I think the nurse is looking for
19 well they may have their own reasons
to want to ask for that degree of pay
rise but again in the Nafi over a pint
uh I'm not terribly sure that will play
very well Soldier Sailors Marines are
very loyal but they're all individuals
with their own decision-making process
and some might say well perhaps um yeah
I'll leave you I mean I'm going to do
something else that's rather better paid
I wouldn't want to see that that would
be a shame what is your view generally
just then of where the Army is in terms
of its numbers I mean you obviously know
that there have been significantly
reduce from from when you were in charge
but the rationale has always been from
the ministry of defense that everything
needs to be smaller more agile more
multifaceted in what they can do is that
what you see in the Army at the moment
um it's what I see it's not what I agree
with however
um I mean you've only got to look at
what's going on in Ukraine at the
present moment Mass matters numbers
matter whether you're in a tank whether
you're on on your feet with a rifle and
our army is dangerously small at the
present moment pretty heavily committed
and of course if the issue of Russia
being a threat remains as a leading
member of NATO we're going to have to
take part in extended deterrent
deployments on the border with Russia
that'll just soak up Manpower and we
haven't got it yeah that is certainly
true at Lord Janet lovely to see you
thank you so much for popping in
let's turn our attention to Ukraine and
just a month ago the people of Carson
were celebrating being liberated from
Russian occupation
but residents there now found themselves
under heavy bombardment from President
Putin's troops and are preparing
themselves for a rather difficult winter
our security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes is in Carson and has this report
punctured dreams one month after Ukraine
recaptured her son City
the owner of this flat was away when the
Russian rocket struck
his neighbor shows us the damage and
weighs up whether it's a price worth
paying to be free
good yeah
[Music]
it's residents like Leonid who are
counting the cost and keeping a record
including the remains of the rocket that
hit his building
outside more evidence of Russia's new
Campaign Of Terror after its occupation
was cut short
the Billboards speak of renewed Freedom
that the reality is one of fear
more than 40 people have died in Russian
strikes since Liberation day on the 11th
of November yes the Russians are out of
hearthstone City but they haven't gone
far they are just on the opposite side
of that bank and they're using that
position to fire rounds into the City
Daily
for those who remain they're no longer
under Russia's rule but still trapped by
its War
Ukrainian authorities are doing what
they can to help
the mayor tries to pacify one woman who
says she needs medicine is life better
now than before when Russia was
occupying
it's a very different atmosphere from a
month ago when crowd celebrated Russia's
Retreat
it's very dangerous here is there a lot
of problems here Allah
this Spirit of endurance is captured
most strongly in here the maternity
hospital
Julia discovered she was pregnant during
Russia's occupation that gave birth
after the Ukrainian liberation
rather
foreign they're not planning to leave
her son
but for those who've had enough this
evacuation train offers a route out
it's one Victoria and her two children
have finally decided to take
um
we should leave
despite her grief Victoria is sure of
one thing
all this pain will be worthwhile
provided Russia plays no part in
Ukraine's future
Deborah Haynes Sky News in Herson City
some of the day's other headlines now
and the European Union's top official
has called for the creation of an
independent ethics body covering all its
institutions police raided European
Parliament offices following allegations
of corruption Belgian prosecutors have
charged four people over the weekend
with that participation in any criminal
group and money laundering
Twitter has dissolved its trust and
Safety Council which advised it on hit
speech child exploitation self-harm and
other problems on the platform from back
in 2016 the council was made up of
volunteers from around 100 civil human
rights and other independent
organizations since taking over Twitter
Elon Musk has valued an overhaul to make
it profitable
police in the Bahamas have arrested Sam
bankman fright uh the founder of the
bankrupt crypto firm FTX the country's
attorney general said they received
formal notification from the U.S that
criminal charges had been filed against
him there and that it was likely there
would be a request for his extradition
Mr Bachman Freud had been under
investigation by the United States after
his 32 billion dollar company suddenly
filed for bankruptcy last month
foreign
almost 34 years after the Lockerbie
disaster an elderly man accused of
making the bomb has faced the U.S court
the former Libyan intelligence operative
faces or several life sentences if
convicted but not the death penalty our
U.S correspondent Mark Stone has the
detail
the faces of some of the 270 victims of
the Lockerbie bombing remembered outside
a Washington Courthouse
on the day the man alleged to be at the
heart of the plot to bring down flight
103 was inside
the so-called Third Man the American
government alleges that this was the
Lockerbie bomb maker inside in a green
jumpsuit and with help from a translator
he confirmed his name but was not asked
to enter a plea face to face with him in
court some of the families of those who
died a woman with her daughter but no
husband a man with his father but no
mother
just a few of so many families made
incomplete by the worst terror attack in
British history
Pan Am flight 103 was half an hour into
its Journey from Heathrow to New York
when it exploded at 31 000 feet over the
Scottish town of Lockerbie
there was a long investigation a
reconstruction diplomacy and awkward
Politics the Libyan government admitted
responsibility
Abdul Basit al-magrahi was convicted he
later died another man was acquitted and
in 2012 the third man Masood then in
custody in Libya allegedly confessed to
being the bomb maker it would take
another 10 years for his transfer to the
U.S how he got here the Americans will
say only it was lawful well she was
looking forward to coming back for
Christmas from school Paul Hudson's
daughter Molina was on the flight and
for him this is a huge moment the fact
that we're here today is The Testament
to the tenacity and and the confidence
of both the Scottish and UK authorities
as well as the American ones Mr Masood
will be back in court later this month
for the next stage in a painful story
which stretches back so many years Mark
Stone Sky News in Washington
six people have been killed during a
standoff at a remote property in the
Australian state of Queensland police
were responding to reports of a missing
person when authorities say they were
ambushed let's try and dig a little bit
more into this one Sky's Nicole Johnson
joins us now from Sydney Nicole good to
see you and just bring us up to date how
much do we actually know of what took
place in this Farm
well the police authorities are still
trying to work out what was the exact
motive behind you but behind this case
but it was an extraordinary situation on
Monday night four police officers
arrived at this property around 300
kilometers 150 miles in the Outback West
of Brisbane they were met with a hail of
bullets two police officers were killed
and perhaps what is so shocking is that
they were killed execution style the
other two officers went for cover and
one of them was in some long grass the
assailants the attackers then Set Fire
to the grass
another neighbor came he was killed in
the end more than a dozen police
officers arrived on the scene to try and
bring it to an end and the three alleged
suspects were killed this took around
six hours so an incredible sort of night
in a remote uh part of the state and the
police commissioner has said that the
other two police officers were lucky to
to get away with their lives
many thanks
and more on that story of course as we
get it but stay where you are after the
break I will be discussing the skiing
destination just that little bit closer
to home hoping to rebound from all those
covet setbacks that's next
[Music]
welcome back after struggling through
covet and poor snowfall yesterday was
the first day of the ski season for the
Glen shoe Resort in Scotland uh very
pleased to see joining us now Callie
Gordon uh who's been a ski instructor
there for most of his life Cali lovely
to talk to you this morning
um before we talk about the the coming
season just tell us how the past couple
of years have been with particularly
with the the restrictions placed on you
with covert
back in uh 2019 we had actually one of
the last uh better Seasons but um that
that's when the covered was just
arriving and about March time we had to
close down early but we had a really
good season up until then and when she
was pretty covered and yeah really good
and since then obviously they're 2020 we
got about six days and had to shut down
due to covid which was one of the best
one of the best snow covers I've seen
for about 10 years so quite disappointed
about that
then
um managed to get themselves a really
good snow making machine so we we worked
a lot on um artificial school last year
and uh we made it work really well they
tried hard we tried hard we got um
hundreds of kids skiing adult skiing so
yeah it was good for mental health and
good for fitness
how's the how's the snow looking this
season then it's looking very good it's
uh yeah it's quite surprising um I was
up yesterday and uh it's looking really
good for for this time of the year
normally we're we're working on just um
artificial snow but um a lot of really
um yeah a lot of nice looking real stuff
up there so yeah it's looking quite
promising
fantastic and it is a beautiful part of
the world that in fact I've been to a
couple of times um but you know for for
those who don't possess our accent and
our knowledge uh of the ski community in
Scotland
um you know most people when they think
of going going for a skiing holiday
decide oh let's go chamonix let's head
somewhere in the Alps so on and so forth
what what why would you sell Glenn she
to the rest of the world
um local local and Scotland but it's um
it has some really good features you
know we don't have the tree cover for
the wind but we've had some really good
Alpine days and some good off-piece
skiing
um a lot of people don't realize over
the back of Glenn she there's some
really good snow and yeah and so you've
got to support your local people when so
it's good to it's good to get local
people up here we had people from France
a couple of years ago that came over
they had a bad season there so sometimes
when it's bad in Europe it's good here
and vice versa yeah and and it's just
that another kind of little point in
your favor it's a downside cheaper than
going to Valdez here I suspect that's
quite a big point being Scottish for a
great Thrifty with our money so yeah I
think you'll get you'll get a half-price
holiday here compared with abroad
definitely
and better banter indeed indeed um so
how confident are you given you know the
couple of years of difficulty that you
would have had that those days are
passed they're actually you know with
the the ski season now opening up you
know Glenn she might actually be able to
earn itself at the earn itself the money
that it used to in in summer in Seasons
past I should say
yeah I think
snow making machine which is
guaranteeing uh snow for at least six
weeks for me as a as a provider I do
skill lessons for a local school so that
is very encouraging and that's gonna
give me a job and a lot other people a
job for the next six weeks at least till
we see where the real snow goes but it's
very promising at the moment and
hopefully hopefully they get a good
season to keep them alive and keep them
going
uh well Kelly will keep fingers crossed
and thanks very much for joining us have
a lovely Christmas when it comes okay
thank you bye
time for a quick look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
and it's looking to stay cold into the
weekend with a strengthening wind
bringing a noticeable wind chill from
Wednesday but the wind will at least
keep the fog away there will be a
widespread sharp Frost at first today
and some dense freezing fog over Central
Parts in particular but it will be
mainly dry just a little patchy rain for
the south of Ireland and wintry showers
near Northern and Eastern coasts the
morning looking to be mostly fine
although the fog will linger but the
south of Ireland will be cloudy without
breaks of rain sleet and snow there'll
be wintry showers in the North and the
Northeast too
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
time for a very quick break but
afterwards the transport secretary has
told this program that there is a
reasonable offer on the table for
striking real workers we'll discuss that
more after this
[Music]